These allegations that I
have sent inappropriate pictures
over the internet
are completely ridiculous.
They are levied
by my political rivals
who are trying to embarrass me
and advance their own agenda.
So let me be perfectly clear.
These allegations are false.
I will be vindicated.
- Okay, please, questions.
[all speaking at once]
- Senator, senator.
[overlapping shouting]
TMZ has obtained an actual
photo of your genitalia.
They're posting it
to their website as we speak.
They're saying you took it.
How do you respond?
[cameras clicking]
- Hmm? Okay.
I may have sent one photo
of my genitalia.
- All right?
(reporters) Senator, senator!
Okay, but I assure you
that's an isolated incident.
- It was a one-time thing. Okay?
[overlapping shouting]
- Yes. Mark?
- Senator,
what about the new report
that there are three
new pictures
having been sent
to three different women?
That's not a one-time thing.
That's a lot of--
What second-rate news
organization is trying to--
New York Times.
(all)
Oh...oh...
O--
It was--it was four total.
- No more. That was it.
[all speaking at once]
It was just--
It was four, and no more.
Questions? Yes, Amy.
Yes, you are sure that there
were only four photos sent?
That's it. Four. That's all.
There's no more than four.
Then how do you explain
the one you sent me?
- What?
[all gasping]
Everybody please, please.
I'm begging you.
I'm begging you to forgive me
for the foibles
and transgressions.
It was the reckless act
of a younger man.
A younger man?
You sent it two seconds
before you stepped on stage.
(man)
Senator, senator,
that's very recent.
Yeah, Amy,
last time I checked,
time is still real, okay?
So, technically speaking...
[text message dings]
I am much older now
than I was
- all of those seconds ago.
[all cell phones beeping]
- Did I just--
- Are you guys--
- Oh, my God, yeah.
- What?
- What's happening right now?
- I just got one.
[all speaking at once]
Senator,
how are you even doing this?
You have no proof
that I am doing anything--
- [all gasping]
- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
I'm sorry. I'm sorry again.
I'm sorry again.
I'm sorry one more time.
Oh, wait a second.
You can do it,
but I can't do it?
[overlapping shouting]
Get in there, get in there.
[all groaning]
Oh!